SURE THEY'RE DIALED IN EARLY TH
GAMES.
SMITH, ALMOST JAMS THAT REBOUND
HOME AND THE WORK,
HARNARAYAN.
>> Harnarayan: MOST CERTAINLY,
SCOTT.
IT'S A TREND WE'VE SEEN THIS AT.
WERE PREVENTEDED
HE HASN'T SHOT
TO THE DANGER ZONE.
REBOUND MIGHT HAVE GAVE IT.
PASS.
IT'S IN THE KINGS' ZONE.
ANDERSON HAS RICOCHETS TO GRUND
THE KINGS MAKE THEIR
THE KINGS WERE ON THE ATTACK.LI.
THEY TURN IT OVER AND THEN RIGHT
THEREE
AGAIN.
DUSTIN BROWN CLEARS THE ZONE.
KULAK I I
POSSESSION HERE, GOES TO CHIP IT
OUT...
PICKED OFF BY DUSTIN BROWN.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF TIME AND
SPACE.UCK
DOWN THE ICE.
KINGS ABLE TO MAKETO WITH A REA
>> Louie: GREAT PUSH HERE BY THE
>> Harnarayan: "HOCKEY NIGHT IN
CANADA" PANEL TALKEDGAME.
ONLY THREE SHOTS FOR EACH IN THE
ATHANASIOU WAS LURKING NEAR THE
NET.
ATHANASIOU AND PANICKY
AS EDMONTON TRYING TO CHOP  TRA.
YOU SEE ALL THE PENALTY KILL
OVER TO THE DRAISAITL.
HE'S GOT McDAVID WITH HIM.
McDAVID, POWERINGWELL.
DRAISAITL THE FOLLOWER.
AS HE'S
NUGENT-HOPKINS BACK TO McDAVID,
DRAISAITL SHOOTS, SCORES!
AGGRESSIVE PENALTY KILL BY THE
LOS ANGELES KINGS.
WHEN HE ATTACKS THE NET,
EVERYBODY
THEENE.
DIDN'T MATTER WHO WAS WITH
McDAVID AND DRAISAITL, THEY HAD!
IT'S THE GAME WINNER AND THE LOS
ANGELES KINGS LEAD